الذي يشفعون
يعلم ما بين ايديهم وماهم
ولا يحون بشيء من علمه الا بما شاء وسياق
السيماوات
والارض
حفظ ما
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد يقول
الحافظ النووي رحمه الله تعالى في كتابه
رياض الصالحين في باب فضل يوم الجمعه
وعن ابي هريره رضي الله عنه ان رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم ذكر يوم الجمعه
فقال فيها ساعه لا يوافقها عبد مسلم وهو
قائم يصلي يسال الله شيئا الا اعطاه اياه
واشار بيده يقللها
اشار بيده يقللها يعني هكذا الا اعطاه
الله اياه متفق عليه
ابي هريره النووي رحمه
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
جمعه
يوم الجمعه
‏in which no
will
be standing praying asking Allah for
anything except that Allah will give it
to him and then he with his hand
to articulate that it is
easy for subالى as if it is nothing for
subالى
so we have in this narration that there
is a
جمعه
hours
in
دعاء is expected
and definitely answered
is
hopefully answered
at all times. ‏But there are certain
times when dua is definitely answered
promised to be answered provided the
conditions are fulfilled provided those
things which stop oura from being
answered by Allah areent
and so this is one of the times when we
are guaranteed our will answer by الله
سبحانه وتعالى
صلى الله عليه وسلم
جمعه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
دعاء
[Silence]
‏could anyollowing
nar
صلى الله عليه
وعن ابي برده
ابن ابي موسى الاشعري رضي الله عنه قال
قال عبد الله ابن عمر رضي الله عنهما
اسمعت اباك يحدث
عن رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم في شان
ساعه الجمعه؟ قال قلت نعم سمعته يقول سمعت
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول هي ما
بين ان يجلس الامام الى ان تقضى الصلاه
رواه مسلم هذه الروايه من
جمله الروايات القليله جدا هي معدوده على
اصابع اليد الواحده
التي في صحيح الامام مسلم او في صحيح
الامام البخاري التي الراجح فيها انها
مدرجه ايش يعني مدرجه؟ يعني في لغه
المحدثين المدرج من الحديث
هو ان يحدث الراوي بالحديث والمستمع
يظن كلام الراوي هو كلام الرسول صلى الله
عليه وسلم فيدرج كلام الراوي ويخلطه بكلام
ويلحقه
بكلام الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم وان كان
الراجح انه ليس كلام الرسول بل هو كلام
الراوي هذا اسمه مدرج وهو من اي قسم
الضعيف لانه لا يثبت عن الرسول صلى الله
عليه وسلم وانما هو خطا الاسناد يكون
صحيحا والكلام يكون صحيحا لكن لا يكون
صحيحا من كلام رسول الله هذا الحديث مما
ذكر العلماء رحمهم الله والمحدثون
وعامه المحدثين انه من قسم المدرج هذا من
كلام ابن عمر وليس من كلام النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم اذ يضطرب
مع جميع من روى هذه الروايه ولم يرفعها
الى النبي سبب عله اسناديه وكذلك ذلك لانه
يصطدم مع حديث صحيح عند النسائي يخالف هذا
الكلام
موسى الاشعري
برده
ابو موسى الاشعري
was
asked
عبد الله بن عمر رضي الله عنهما
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
دعاء answer
الله بن
‏I
say that time is by the narration we
just wasing about is between the time
when the
sit on
صلاه overلا
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏ing handl
themselves of narration is correct
however the words themselves are
actually the words of the narrator that
confused into
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله
جمعه
asked
‏prop
time could anyon
thatek
out
the second here
are not
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ابن عمر
الله عنهم
‏was
time
as
we will another
time الله سبحانه وتالى
بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان يغفر لنا خطايانا وان
يتوب علينا وان يتقبل منا
عملنا وان يرزقنا فعل الخيرات وترك
المنكرات وحب المساكين والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب العالمين